Professor Robert spolski you were once
asked what was the most powerful moment
that you've had when you were
investigating primates and you recounted
the tale of Benjamin so I'd like you to
retell that for our audience and also
explain its significance to you
please well Benjamin just as orientation
um for more than 30 years uh I spent my
summmer studying a population of wild
baboons in a national park in East
Africa going back to the same animals
each
year and you know beginning to feel
fairly connected to them after a while
um amid having the usual primatologist
rules of like don't interact and don't
interfere and that kind of thing um
there was one baboon who I was very very
fond of named Benjamin who was a bit of
a bozo might be the most appropriate way
of stating it um and like if there were
you know stinging ants to step on he was
going to step on it every time if there
was a bunch of like thorns in the bushes
he was the one who was going to stumble
into it um but very fond of him and I
was doing an observational sample on him
one day where you sit there and you
write down everything that he does for
30 minutes and he proceeded to spend the
whole time asleep this was the middle of
the day and he was under a bush and fell
asleep so I sat there for these riveting
30 minutes and by the time that was over
and he happened to wake up then uh we
discovered all the other baboons had
left us all the other baboons were just
all foraging and they were nowhere to be
seen and he sort of looked around and
freaked out and I got up on top of my
Jeep and binoculars and looked around
and finally spotted them on like some
distant Hill and there was a moment
where he then looked at me and
projecting and anthropomorphizing all of
that but he knew that I knew where they
were and I got back in the Jeep and
drove very slowly while he sort of
trotted alongside and we found the other
baboons and that was just like a moment
of a sense of connection like nothing I
had ever felt
before is that allowed because you sense
that he knew what you were thinking and
he sensed that you had this knowledge
and you're not allowed to intervene but
you're like I want to help this
guy yeah it's very it's very squishy
because you know to some extent you know
you're not a fly on the wall you're
you're a close relative in lots of ways
I I had one occasion where this juvenile
male communicated to me in a way that
was pretty demeaning um there's a
vocalization that you know you're some
lower ranking baboon you're about to get
Trashed by some higher ranking guy it's
perfectly obvious and there's a
distinctive facial expression you make
at that point which is to everybody else
saying is anybody interested in coming
and watching my back on this and and
defending me so this was this squirly
little juvenile who had irritated
somebody and this big male was clearly
about to just trounce him and you could
see the kid did this can anybody join me
facial expression that everybody else
around him and of course nobody else
wanted to get involved and you could see
in a moment of sheer desperation he
looked at me and made the facial
expression which I thought was
phenomenal it was phenomenal from the
standpoint of he was hoping I would
understand what he was saying inter
species communication at the same time I
was extremely sort of disted because
once again I was the last resort I was
the last one being picked for the team
every everybody else said no okay might
as well like try him as if he was hoping
I would like run over the guy with my
Jeep or something so that that was a
fairly unique moment and and tragically
I had to pretend I didn't understand
what he was saying and he got trounced
but that was that was a fairly special
moment of all the species you could have
studied and humans being one of them why
did you choose
baboons well I didn't choose them I was
I was shipped off to them my first love
were mountain gorillas and I was like
eight when I decided I was going to go
study mountain gorillas up in the
mountains of the Moon and central Africa
all of that and um it turned out that
was not a place logistically very easy
to go do fieldwork in and I also kind of
turned into a physiologist and was
interested in hormones and these guys
and you're not going to do physiology on
mountain gorillas it was just plausible
um so baboons made a ton of sense they
live in these big social groups they
live out in the open they are not end
dangered any of that stuff in contrast
to mountain gorillas and I kind of
inherited my troop from a grad student
who was just finishing up his thesis at
the time so you know everybody can't go
and live with mountain gorillas you got
to adapt to circumstances so instead 30
plus years with baboons
right and you use the word well use the
phrase I didn't choose that and we're
going to get to that because your latest
book is determined yes like I mentioned
off air that I went through determined
with a fine- tooth comb as well as
behave and why zebras get ulcers so I
have some questions about all three but
we'll start with determined so in a
passage fairly early on in the book
maybe chapter 2 or three he said these
are questions that you mentioned
philosophers POs to you that left you
gasping in defamed awe quote unquote
what does it mean to become aware of a
conscious decision what do deciding and
intending actually mean can you decide
to decide so I will ask you Professor
what does it mean to become aware of a
conscious decision what do deciding and
intending actually mean and can you
decide to
decide well the way in which I get in
everyone's faces at this point is that
what does it mean that you've become
aware of a conscious decision let's
Translate that into what does it tell us
about Free Will and where I am a major
irritant is my conclusion is it tells us
nothing about Free Will whatsoever
conscious intent has nothing to do with
the Free Will debate whether that was
conscious or unconscious has nothing to
do with it and one of my starting
arguments in the book which is that we
have no free will whatsoever all we are
is the outcome of our biology over which
we had no control and his interaction
with environment over which we had no
control and sort of the strongest way in
which people cling to a free will belief
is you make a decision you decide I'm
going to have you know chocolate ice
cream instead of vanilla you were
conscious of it you are conscious of
your intent you know you're not being
coerced into doing that you're not being
forced you have other options you know
that there's a good likelihood that if
you say chocolate you're going to be
given chocolate ice cream so you're
you're like you understand the
contingencies there and you make a
choice you act on your intent and for
the vast majority of people that's a
moment that just resonates with free
will that just feels it's so palpable
it's so in the moment and the
Consciousness seems so important and for
me it's completely irrelevant it is like
asking somebody to review a movie and
they only get to see the last 3 minutes
of it because what that analysis leaves
out is the only question you can ask at
that point where did that intent come
from how did you become that sort of
person not only the sort of person who
would prefer chocolate to vanilla but a
person who would be ordering ice cream
at that point a person who had the
socioeconomic luxury of doing so a
person who liked the taste of a person
who it how did you become who you are at
that moment and what made you who you
are is all that biology interacting with
environment over which you had no
control and we are nothing more or less
in the outcome of what came be before
and in that regard conscious or
otherwise in the moment an incredible
sense of intentionality right in front
of your face or an off-handed one none
of it matters in this life us because
the only question to ask is how did you
become the sort of person you are in
that moment and you had no control over
that so why isn't the argument much more
simple by saying look you're determined
by the laws of physics whether the laws
of physics have indeterminacy to them
whatever you're determined by the laws
of physics and you don't determine the
laws of physics so therefore you have no
free will why isn't it as simple as that
why do we go through a rigar of biology
and neurology and psychology
well if we're having some nice
interdisciplinary sort of hegemony here
yeah you know it's ultimately all down
to physics and the physicist only talk
to God sort of thing you know it happens
that my training is such that it is most
accessible to me from the standpoint of
biology but yeah ultimately it's that
level as well um it doesn't mean there
are not features of it at the biological
level that could only be understood at
the biological level like any emergent
system and it's just been easiest for me
over the years in terms of my training
and proclivities to be like much more
interested in the brain than in
cosmology or something but ultimately
it's the same exact thing it's a
material universe and nobody who is
willing to admit it is a material
universe and there are things like atoms
and cells and stuff out there um nobody
who gives in as a starting point to that
and then says somehow there's still free
will none of them can provide a
mechanism in which somehow you can step
outside all of those rules every now and
then and that's when we're acting freely
we're just biological machines we're
materialist machines we are complicated
ones Beyond imagination but yeah that's
all there is and nobody arguing for free
will can come up with something that
does not rely upon a magical step of
nonsense somewhere in the
analysis much of this comes down to the
definition of Free Will so what would be
your definition of Free Will um it's one
that infuriates the philosophical
compatibilists the one who say yes it's
a material
world but somehow that's compatible with
free will it's infuriating to them in
fact two weeks ago I had a debate with
Daniel dennet in case you didn't know
I've spoken to Daniel dennet for about 3
hours it's a large Behemoth podcast and
it's already out the link is in the
description in fact two weeks ago I had
a debate with Daniel dennet who's one of
the most you know visible of philosophy
compatibilists and he actually used the
word daff he said I was being daed and
insisting on this as a definition of
Free Will whereas for me I think is the
only possible thing okay so
a behavior happens and you ask why did
that occur did that person just exercise
Free Will where did that behavior come
from and you're asking what went on to
the brain a second ago but you're also
asking what of the environment over the
previous minutes to hours triggered that
behavior and you're also asking what did
this morning's hormone levels have to do
with how sensitive the brain would be to
that and then you're asking what have
previous months been about in terms of
true neural plasticity you're asking
about adolescence and childhood and even
fetal life where what was going on then
was directing the brain you had at this
moment you're asking something about
genes you're asking something about the
culture your ancestors invented because
that was going to influence how your
mother was mothering you within minutes
of birth and it turns out that makes a
difference why did that behavior occur
because of everything from a second ago
to a million years ago and how does one
then Define free will if if you want to
prove there's free will show me that
this brain just produced a behavior and
show me it would have produced the exact
same behavior independent of its history
leading up to it that moment change that
morning's hormone levels change the
genome change what the fetal environment
was like change the color of the socks
that person is wearing today change all
of those and if you still get the exact
same behavior you've just proven free
will
because you've demonstrated behavior
that is being an uncaused cause that is
independent of its history and you can't
and nobody who argues for free will can
show how that occurs because it is so
embedded in this Matrix of everything
that got you to that moment that there's
simply no wiggle room in there to say
and then for half a second biology and
the physical laws of the universe it
gets turned off for half a second and
then you decide to do what you do if you
enjoyed that clip then the full podcast
is out right now you can click around
here enjoy subscribe to theories of
everything to get notified of upcoming
podcasts as there are new full length
podcasts every week on the topics of
mathematics physics Consciousness Free
Will and
AI